in much of the world we've been going
through a housing crisis for years now
rent prices are in the sky swallowing
more and more of our salaries worse
owning a home is increasingly becoming a
distant Impossible Dream for younger
Generations meanwhile private developers
unless regulated otherwise put up mostly
luxury units even though what's really
needed is affordable housing on a large
scale if we put up tens of thousands of
affordable units in an affected City
network is the housing crisis but it
would also cut significantly into real
estate companies bottom line imagine if
vonovia's average selling can rent
prices per square meter dropped by half
that would mean happy tenants relieved
family budgets and absolutely Furious
investors
all this is to say private developers
alone will not solve the problem without
any meaningful large-scale public
intervention the housing crisis is here
to stay or is it what's this area of
Hope a light in the darkness a Tesla
burning bright in the night showing us
the way confirmed genius Elon Musk is
here to lead us out of the housing
crisis with his cheap prefabricated epic
future homes or is he well stay tuned if
we're talking affordable housing Elon
Musk is your man as musk fans point out
every single time whether anyone ask him
or not Elon Musk is not your average
billionaire instead of the usual
gigantic mention he lives in a small
modest fifty thousand dollar prefab home
so he obviously understands the plight
of the common masses having descended to
them what a saint that's the legend
anyway according to various sources musk
mostly lives in Austin in the mention of
his billionaire friend in the meantime
he's also been shopping around the city
for his own gigantic luxury compound so
there's that but no matter Elon Musk is
here to solve the housing crisis so
let's not look at gift Emerald mine in
the mouth Elon Musk fan channels promise
nothing less than a lure epic 420 Marvel
vibranium ten thousand dollar affordable
home wow but the problem is in true Elon
Musk fashion these tiny futuristic
prefab affordable homes will not solve
the housing crisis if anything they
could actually make it worse also they
aren't real but we'll get to that how is
that possible let's find out after I
recover from the brain damage I got from
watching some of these videos the sheer
amount of dick riding Jesus Christ Elon
Musk is the man behind this Innovative
home is dedicated to reducing his carbon
footprint and promoting sustainability
in all aspects of his life Towing the
house with a Tesla cyber truck makes
more sense in my opinion because of its
increased towing capability this would
probably be the most time and fuel
efficient option the interdependence of
Tesla products is surely something to
Marvel at it's a tech Lover's Dream Come
True Elon Musk fans will be the end of
me but as I spiral into Insanity at
least my buddy's daily needs are
properly met by ag1 ag1 is a Whole Food
daily dietary supplement containing 75
vitamins minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients it's gluten and dairy free
low calorie and vegan eg1 is unique as
it's one of the most comprehensive
supplements on the market right now and
it's made with the highest quality
ingredients preparing it is very easy
just put a spoonful into your glass of
water mix and done ag-1 has a mild
Pleasant taste and a nice texture its
supports our immune system maintains
your energy level and boosts your body's
natural recovery process it's especially
useful if you do training or any other
heavy physical exercise personally since
I started taking ag1 in the morning
generally I've been feeling better and
healthier and more energetic
foreign
which means I can genuinely recommend it
to my viewers get yourself a pack of ag1
using the link in the description and
enjoy its benefits to your mind and body
today thank you for checking out ag1
it's like this help support me in
creating more content for you and now
back to the video
so Elon musk's ten thousand dollar
affordable homes which will apparently
help solve the housing crisis and why
they absolutely won't Elon Musk meet
writer channels help popularize this
idea that musk is creating an affordable
ten thousand dollar futuristic Home and
these videos got quite popular garnering
hundreds of thousands of views one of
them going as high as 12 million they
all claim to present Elon musk's epic
affordable tiny home this online code
consists of two sects the 15 000 Tesla
home evangelists and the Church of the
50 000 tiny home let's take a look at
the letter first just fifty thousand
dollars for what looks like a shipping
container with Windows sign me the hell
up so when will Elon Musk be shipping
these things how many thousands of hours
of planning did this genius have to sink
into this incredible project how many
tens of thousands are Tesla factor is
churning out right as we speak
zero on both counts Elon Musk has
nothing to do with this this is the
Casita accessory dwelling unit from a
company called boxable what's Elon
musk's connection to it according to me
Trader channels he lives in a casita in
Texas and this is complete [__] how
do I know because Elon Musk tweeted as
much I've actually been living living in
a fifty thousand dollar house in South
South Texas for past two years uh not
not not boxable uh cool product though
this tidbit of course didn't stop the
meat Riders from misleadingly calling it
Elon musk's 50 000 home anything for
those views I guess by the way it's
called the Casita accessory dwelling
unit because it's not supposed to be a
standalone home accessory dwelling units
or adus are supposed to be attached to
or next to irregular house so I don't
know why they're pretending this is
supposed to be a standalone thing anyway
so how about that fifteen thousand
dollar Tesla home then that it is nicely
visualized looking sleek and futuristic
and it's complete [__] this does not
exist as far as I can tell the
originator was the channel called Elon
Musk rewind a particularly prolific
misinformation Hub run by some atiq
cloud chaser and man when it comes to
chasing views this channel is more
desperate than your high school female
friends 40 boyfriend Elon Musk
officially bought Mercedes he didn't
Elon Musk is producing combat Bots to
beat Russia he isn't Elon Musk just
revealed Tesla Model Pi official release
date he did no such thing despite all
this sweaty desperate clout chasing most
of these videos don't even break a
hundred thousand views which is pretty
funny but they did manage to fart out
two videos in late 2021 and early 2022
which became massively popular both of
them about the supposed Tesla home and
in both of these videos they talk about
something completely different namely
the aforementioned 50 000 boxable home
okay but then what are those tiny hopes
on the thumbnail they even have the
Tesla logo on so they must be some super
secret high IQ Elon Musk project
actually that's the cube 2 mobile home
by nestron and Company with Vegeta musk
once again has absolutely nothing to do
with what is it doing at all those
thumbnails clickbait that's it just
clickbait Elon Musk rewind Googled
futuristic tiny home then took the first
image result put a Tesla logo.png on it
and plastered it all over his videos and
this dude really just can't help himself
two days before re-recording this he
released the same video for the third
time once again with the nestron cube 2
on the thumbnail with the obligatory
clickbaity title once again showing the
boxable Casita in the actual video with
a metric ton of stock footage and the
obligatory meat riding right next to a
SpaceX company it's a small but cozy
space that Eli calls home but with five
teenagers from his first marriage
including twins who are 18 years old and
triplets Who are 16 years old you might
be wondering how he manages to fit
everyone in such a small house seeing
the success of Elon Musk rewind's
original 2 videos other cloudsharking
channels went absolutely berserk and
started manufacturing the same video
over and over again about the supposed
15 000 Tesla home to cash in on the
interest they put out video after video
after video after video after video
after video about the supposed 15 000
Tesla home they even copied each other's
titles and thumbnails just this one
channel called Elon Musk Zone has made
15 videos to date covering the same same
subject meanwhile over here in reality
the only thing Tesla ever created in
terms of housing was the Tesla tiny home
a small trailer they tutor and Australia
a bit some years ago which was just a
small demonstrator for their Solar
Energy Products so okay Elon Musk is not
building affordable homes he does not
own a boxable home and he has nothing to
do with either boxable or nestron but
what if he did what if Elon Musk really
entered the affordable tiny hole market
and started selling them for fifteen
thousand dollars would that sell be
housing crisis
no God no Jesus aged Christ on a bicycle
no and why is that a few things let's
imagine you got a brand new futuristic
tiny home for free living in an
expensive city and spending two-thirds
of your paycheck on rent you cannot
believe you finally get to own your own
home
your phone vibrates you get an email
from the delivery company we're on the
way with your brand new affordable
futuristic tiny home please enter the
address of your plot blood oh I guess
you need to buy a place to put your
brand new tiny home
you could get some cheap land outside
the city I mean outside the city which
if you don't mind a two plus hour daily
car commute per direction or the lack of
broadband internet and possible drinking
water it's just a place for you so here
we see the first big contradiction of
tiny affordable homes namely that in
urban areas where they're most needed
plots and land are also incredibly
expensive and in areas where plots are
cheap houses and departments will be
cheap too and at that point why even
bother with your tiny home just get a
regular one at a low price the other big
contradiction of these affordable tiny
homes is their scalability these things
aren't designed to be stacked on top of
each other and mass so if you have say a
hectare or building plot that's 10 000
square meters you could fit 96 of these
tiny homes on it each of them being a 6
meter by 6 meter cube plus a little
Garden area but cities also have these
things called parking regulations which
means you need to have x amount of
parking per unit in this case how many
you need varies from area to area but
let's say here it's one to one that's 16
tiny homes gone replaced by parking
leaving us with 80. though that still
sounds like a decent number however the
same area could fit 92 row houses with a
184 households in them possibly more
depending on how high you build that's
more than double the units okay you
might say but what if we then put these
tiny homes real close together to
increase density which yeah it's called
a refugee camp what a great idea we
could even have a bunch of these at the
edges of town and we could organize
these fun competitions between them
every year each tiny home District 2 is
a champion then all Champions are put
together in a fighting arena of sorts
where they battle each other to the
death the last surviving champion in the
district they represent could then win
some fun prizes like Amazon vouchers or
something joke aside or is it really a
joke at this point I don't know anyway
the other tiny home the nestron cube 2
is just a fancy trailer so with these
two tiny homes if you take away all the
fancy futuristic [__] and the tech
bro hype your two choice are either
living in a refugee camp or in a trailer
park I don't know about you but that's
not how I Envision living my life and
the tragic thing is these companies
don't bring anything new to the table
let's take the 50 000 boxable home as an
example I looked up the websites of some
local hardware stores and wow would you
look at that they do seem to be in the
business of revolutionizing home
affordability or something for half the
price you can get an entire house from
this epic eco-friendly renewable
material called wood and they'll even
deliver to you for free compared to
boxables three to ten dollars per mile
from Las Vegas granted you would need to
spend some money on plumbing and
insulation but in the end it would still
be cheaper these Hardware storehouses
have been available for many years and
yet they didn't solve the housing crisis
anywhere that's because these tiny
affordable houses are fundamentally
unable to do so for the reasons we've
discussed they need land which tends to
be expensive where housing is needed and
they scale horribly housing only a
fraction of the people in the giving
plot that a normal apartment building
would so what are the actual solutions
to the housing crisis here the ultimate
solution would be a large scale
state-run public housing construction
project but this is rather unlikely in
most places given our current political
climate instead what could also help is
the elimination of parking minimums
those dense Lively American Row House
neighborhoods or those old beautiful
European residential districts would be
illegal to build today pretty much
everywhere because they don't have
enough parking spaces if however we get
rid of these requirements and said that
buildings within say 400 meters of a
tram Metro train stop do not need to
have any parking spaces suddenly the
cost of building new housing would go
down because you wouldn't need to
construct expensive underground parking
garages or parking houses through this
more smaller players could enter the
real estate market as the cost barrier
is lower meaning you would get a
healthier real estate market not
dominated by just a few large players
though as I said in the beginning these
companies are not really interested in
solving the housing crisis letting
private developers lose alone will not
solve the problem however it can at
least improve the situation from
disastrous to bad which would be a
useful step one of course housing prices
depend on factors other than supply and
demand as well such as income if people
in an area earn a lot of money landlords
can get away with charging a lot more
this means units will remain affordable
for those High salary professionals but
everyone else gets priced out here rent
control can help or creating public
housing for essential workers so for
example the city buys up some apartments
around the center and then rents them
out at minimal prices to essential
workers like teachers nurses garbage
collectors and so on who otherwise
couldn't afford to live within practical
distance of their own workplaces
necessary for the basic functioning of
the city if the garbage collector has to
commute four hours per day to get to
that workplace you will not have a
garbage collector that sort of thing
other possible measures include the
heavy regulation of short-term rentals
and forcing developers to build more
affordable housing within a given
project and of course if politically
feasible large-scale affordable public
housing projects tiny homes just won't
get us out of this mess we will not
solve the housing crisis with Edge of
Town trailer parks or Tech Pro refugee
camps no matter how futuristic they look
we need public intervention and we need
it yesterday that is bold measures from
our leaders up to it including large
scale public housing construction
projects so do look up your local
political parties what they have done
and what they plan on doing to alleviate
the housing crisis limiting Airbnb
instituting gear and ceiling expanding
social housing that sort of thing so
this was my take on this futuristic
affordable homes thank you for watching
and if you want to support me making
more content like this you can either
become a member on YouTube or support me
on patreon and I'll be seeing you next
time
Kitty what do you think of futuristic
trailer parks
Kitty what do you think of large scale
public housing